c'est nommons l'audience et reprises
je vous rappelle qu'aujourd'hui ici à
rennes
nous jugeons albert uderzo qui est
inculpé d'outragé au peuple breton
raison bien sûr de ce fameux ray du
breton que l'on retrouve dans tous les
albums d'astérix de discrimination
sexuelle puisqu'il n'ya pratiquement pas
de femmes dans des aventures d'astérix
l'apologie de la drogue puisque ces
héros ont besoin sans cesse de potion
magique pour venir à bout de leurs
ennemis et enfin il est inculpé
d'exhibitionnisme puisqu'il montre sa
gaule à tous les passants et la gaule
justement baptisé et la gaule à un
organe un menhir
non mon pauvre vieux c'est dans le
domaine particulier je ne sais pas dans
le domaine public
la gaule 10 waj un organe ou plus
exactement la société française à un
porte parole
c'est le procureur général de la
république des proches française
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
mais ni remontant ses procureurs ne
faisait que temps françaises français
belles belles elles viennent
il est vilain
[Musique]
mongeau zoo désolant de petites olives
noires fripé en équilibre sur son bas
voir ta gueule pdc mesdames et messieurs
les jurés public chéri mon amour bonjour
ma colère s'allume hargne et mon
courroux coût cher cher ami de rennes
chers amis de rennes qui me fait
l'honneur de m'écouter ici ne vous
voilez plus la face ne vous bercez plus
de veine illusion regarder la vérité en
face
car cela ne fait plus l'ombre d'un doute
il suffit de vous voir pour vous en
convaincre
vous êtes tous des minables comment
comment commandes on commet donc dieu me
tripote comment est il possible qu ici à
rennes en plein coeur du pays gaulois ou
devrait encore vibrer plus haut et plus
fort
la flamme éternelle de l'âme armoricaine
et le courage et du courage armoricain
comment est il possible qu ici à rennes
l'ancienne capitale du duché de bretagne
où le savoir jaillissaient des
universités gallo romane pour éclairer
le monde
rennes où la poésie résonnait au fond
des jardins luxuriants rennes ou
l'archevêché au fond de la cour
[Rires]
comment
comment est il possible que des rennais
authentique descendants des premiers
gaulois puisse abc et renier les races
leurs racines au point d'accueillir par
des vivats ce fossoyeur de toutes les
gaules ce soudeur de notre passé cette
épouvantable doryphores de notre culture
qui ricanent sans vergogne sur le
souvenir d'alésia comme un langlois
s'esclaffant sur la douleur muette d'un
prince qui a vu monter personnes êtes
vous seulement un vrai français
uderzo point n'est besoin d'être diplômé
en étymologie mesdames et messieurs les
jurés pour s'apercevoir que dans l'ue
des réseaux il y a eu des qui veut dire
une et herzog qui signifie arzew oran
bon français uderzo ne veulent
strictement rien dire donc uderzo est
juif et donc dreyfus est coupable et si
c'est pas de refus c'est lévis à les
choses de lévis mesdames et messieurs
j'ai vu bien des horreurs tout au long
de cette vie procure orale sans que
jamais frémissent la branche duchesneau
gland inébranlable qu'abrite la robe
austère de la justice sous laquelle
marilyn aurait pas dit non mes yeux en
ont tant vu qu'ils sont devenus gris la
mort de pierrot le fou j étais la sphère
carlo ponti j'y étais oui j'ai vu
descendre pierrot oui je lui monte carlo
mais jamais mais jamais jamais il ne m'a
été donné de voir ce spectacle aussi
dégradant que cet aéropage de ce mythe
est bretonne applaudissant à tout rompre
un vautour de l'anti france dont le
sinistre complice la batterie de
goscinny a refusé de comparaître
aujourd'hui devant nous où est-il
goscinny vous voulez vous qu'il soit cet
irresponsable
vous voulez vous que soit goscinny sinon
au paradis des petits enfants qui rient
des barres de farfelu et des sangliers
sauvages
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout le monde tout le monde ici et là ce
a lu les aventures d'astérix le gaulois
pour vous convaincre
mesdames et messieurs les jurés du crime
antiguos loi de l'accusé et son défunt
complice voulez vous que je vous raconte
la véritable histoire de la gaule bon
même si vous aviez dit non je racontais
quand même et bien voilà au vième siècle
avant le pinocchio de nazareth au 26ème
siècle avant mitterrand si vous êtes
vraiment socialiste hystérique le
voyageur pouvait voir de cheval la gaule
cisalpine oui j'ai bien fait façon à
l'époque c'était le seul moyen de
locomotion le foot comme la gaule
cisalpine la gaule transalpine était
très peuplée de chevaux également mais
aussi de seltz d'armorique un de ligure
aux yeux de braise et d'hubert au teint
olivâtre dont la civilisation basée sur
le culte de la morue se perpétue
aujourd'hui encore jusque dans les
prétoires insufflant tu as cette aimable
maison de la culture de rennes un goût
étrange venu d'ailleurs tout en espérant
le souvenir de jean vilar de lourdes
effluves piscicole dont la presse en
terre sauvage ravivant nous l'image
austère de gérard philipe pénétré du cid
c'est une image jean-philippe entre du
sine rappelons-nous jorat philippe
hurlantes sublime à la fin de l'acte 1
son refus de se battre pour lisbonne
je suis jeune il est vrai mais faut pas
déconner si c'est pour la morue moi j'ai
déjà donné
la civilisation gauloise reposait sur un
gouvernement de riddick composé de
druide sow monnet au portugal et de
druide aux bleus ailleurs les deux
premiers chefs druide s'appelait tard
amir est à rassure c'est cet authentique
c'est pas des faits pas midi à quatorze
heures tard amir ça veut dire le chef
dassier ce qui était fort tu es rassure
ça veut dire le chef petit secteur
assure était le fils de tara bien je
tiens tout ça de d'alain decaux qui
n'est pas un conte sinon ils seraient
pas l'académie française tous deux
furent l'un après l'autre
fortement influencé par la civilisation
grecque c'est ainsi que tara mire est à
rassure me remplace au vème siècle avant
le tintin du golgotha des institutions
de structures typiquement hellénique
il lui successivement deux époques
premièrement l'air hellénique tard amir
et le hellénique tard à seurre
de 58 à 51 avant colombo les de
stigmates césar franck profitant jules
césar franck pardon profitant de la
myopie congénitale des gaulois s'empare
de toute la gaule les manuscrits de
l'époque met en valeur cette véritable
tare ophtalmique de nos ancêtres qui
n'arrivant pas à distinguer les
légionnaires romains même en combat
singulier ne pouvait que c'est crier ils
sont floues c'est romain
en 27 avant super mickey les gaulois les
gaulois divise la gaule en quatre
provinces il confie l'autonomie interne
de la narbonnaise aux narbonnais de
l'aquitaine aux bordelais de la
lyonnaise aux rhodaniens et de la
mayonnaise à l'estragon
c'est la fin d'une époque qui s'était
déjà défaite 30 ans plus tôt lors de la
reddition sans gloire au métro alésia de
vercingétorix le monsieur propre du gui
l'an neuf qui balancent à son épée dans
la gueule de césar au risque de blesser
les ouvriers travaillant à la réfection
de la voie malgré les consignes de
sécurité judicieuse du chef de gare
gallo romain et puis rico l'ososphère 6
la christianisation de la gaule coïncide
avec sa grande époque de prospérité qui
commence à réellement au 1er siècle
après le rantanplan du jourdain
c'est le siècle du développement des
grandes cités lutèce luc dunums si
j'avance à nome comment veux-tu la norme
qui sous entend qu il adore
c'est honteux
en 400 ans après vous je n'en ferai rien
la gaule n'était plus qu'un tas de
ruines fumantes et dévasté que des
meutes hurlantes traverse est à cheval
sans même s'arrêter au péage de rosny
sous bois
soyez maudits gold by gold wisigothe
ostrogoths mandigote grignote duffel
coat redingote il ne s'arrêtait jamais
et caracolait avec le steak tartare bien
au chaud sous les fesses ce qui permis
de les identifier qu'en arrivant à
lutèce ils entrèrent en hurlant à la
samaritaine les câpres coller au cul par
le ketchup
alors alors une femme se leva d'entre
les femmes
elle s'appelait geneviève elle était
belle avec de nombreux saints partout et
suffisamment de fès pour soutenir un
siège
elle n'était pas encore patronne de
paris mais seulement d'un claque de la
rue mouffetard de son corps superbe elle
fit un rempart ou barbe à poux premier
roi des 1,20 s'éclater la zigounette
avant de s'enfuir terrorisé vers la
germanie la frite au fait c'est la
francfort sous le bras alors alors le
vieux druide yvon signe rixe entre adam
l'île saint louis et 10 à barbe à bout
quelle connerie la guerre
[Rires]
donc uderzo est coupable mais son avocat
vous en convaincra mieux que moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est non non